السؤال الان ما هو مصير هؤلاء الاطفال
وزاره الاسره والخدمات الاجتماعيه في
تركيا تشير الى انه في حال انتهت جميع
محاولات التوصل لاسرهم واقاربهم سيقيم
هؤلاء الاطفال في دور رعايه تابعه للدوله
او لدى اسر حاضنه الوزاره تلقت بالفعل
اكثر من خمسه وتسعين الف طلب بهذا الشان
لكن هناك شروط فيما يخص تركيا ان يكون
المحتضن مواطنا تركيا ويقيم داخل البلاد
ان يتراوح عمره بين 25 و 65 عاما وان يكون
حاصلا على مؤهل تعليمي وان يكون لديه دخل
منتظم هذه الطلبات الكثيره علقت عليها
منظمه انقذوا الاطفال بانها ليست الحل
الفوري في هذا الوقت في التبني لا يجب ان
يحدث مباشره بعد حالات الطوارئ التي تنتج
عن الكوارث وفي ظل الانشغال الكبير لانقاذ
ما يمكن لانقاذه من تحت الركام اخر خطر
يخص مستقبل هؤلاء الاطفال امكانيه
استغلالهم من قبل عصابات خطف الاطفال
والاتجار بالبشر نداءات حقوقيه تحذر من
مصير بائس لهم التحذير ذاته شدد عليه
الاختصاصي بقسم الطوارئ في منظمه يونيسف
في هذا النوع من الكوارث كوارث الاطفال
الاطفال معرضون للعنف والاستغلال وسوء
المعامله بما في ذلك خطر الاتجار او العنف
القائم على الجنس